una recta tiene una pendiente de menos
tres cuartos y pasa por el punto cero
ocho cuadras ecuación de la línea en la
forma pendiente ordenada de origen y
bueno todas las líneas rectas se pueden
escribir de la forma pendiente orden al
origen que es la siguiente y es igual a
mx + b donde m esto de aquí es la
pendiente y b es la ordenada al origen
esta es donde se intersecta al eje de la
jez la intersección con el eje de las 10
y bueno déjame graficar la aquí vamos a
suponer que tengo una línea recta en
líbano cartesiano puede ser cualquier
línea recta así que voy a tomarme a mi
plano cartesiano mis dos ejes ordenados
y bueno como tengo una pendiente
negativa entonces voy a dibujar una
línea recta aquí que tenga pendiente
negativa es decir que vaya hacia abajo
ya está y bueno aquí tengo dos conceptos
muy importantes el primero es la
pendiente entonces si tenemos esta
gráfica de color rojo que tenemos aquí y
yo me tomo dos puntos que estén sobre
esta gráfica
entonces la pendiente es el cambio en x
a comparación de lo que cambia en i es
decir lo que nos mide la pendiente es el
cambio en y entre el cambio en x que por
cierto como en este caso mi recta va
hacia abajo lo que quiere decir es que
cuando yo cambio en x positivamente
entonces forzosamente el cambio en ya
debe de ser negativo es decir hacia
abajo 10 esto es lo que nos está
diciendo que tenemos una pendiente
negativa y de igual manera si yo me voy
hacia arriba entonces x tendría que
cambiar hacia la izquierda para tener
una pendiente negativa y bueno esto es
todo lo que corresponde a la pendiente a
hablar del cambio de iu entre el cambio
de x pero otro concepto importante es la
ordenada al origen que es justo el punto
en donde interceptamos el eje de la jr
es decir el punto de la forma 0,10 más
lo puedes ver cuando evaluamos esta
función en x igual a 0 cuando yo
sustituyó el valor de x por 0 me va a
quedar que es igual a m
por cero pero no me por ser o se van
esto es cero entonces simple y
sencillamente me queda que es igual a b
y claro ojo cuando estamos diciendo que
x vale 0 entonces cuando x es 0 y esto
es justo lo que nos da este punto de
aquí el 0,1 ordenada al origen ahora
bien este problema nos dice que tenemos
una pendiente de menos tres cuartos
es decir nuestra pendiente es igual a
menos tres cuartos y además que pasamos
por el punto 0,8 y déjame cambiar de
color para que no sea anaranjado y me
voy a tomar el color verde y entonces
nos dice que pasa por el punto 0,8 y que
nos quiere decir esto bueno entonces
estamos parados en el eje de las 10 en
el punto 0,8 o dicho de otra manera la
intersección con el eje de las 10 es en
el punto 0,8 o mejor aún podemos decir
que b vale 8 porque fíjate aquí tenemos
el punto
y entonces aquí nos está diciendo que
vale 8 y una vez que ya tenemos la
pendiente y que ya tenemos sabemos
entonces podemos sustituir estos valores
en nuestra ecuación de la recta y me
queda que james es igual a menos tres
cuartos de x + b pero me vale 8 entonces
más 8 y es igual a menos tres cuartos de
x más 8 es la respuesta de este problema